المشاهدين الكرام هذه هي الطائره على
الاغلب التي كان يستقلها وهي احدى طائرات
مجموعه فاجنر العسكريه وكما نشاهد على
الخريطه او في الصوره هذا العلم الروسي
وهذا اسم الطائره ليغسي 600 التابعه لشركه
امبراير البرازيليه مصنعه هذه الطائرات
وهذا هو رقم الطائره او احدى طائرات
مجموعه فاجنر وعلى الاغلب وفق البيانات
الملاحيه غير مؤكده حتى هذه اللحظه بنسبه
100% ان هذه الطائره التي تحمل رقم ار اي
02795 هي التي كانت تقل بريكوجين وهذه هي
الطائره التي تحطمت شماليه غربي العاصمه
الروسيه موسكو لكن اين كان اخر ظهور
لبريكوجين هذه اخر صوره التقطت
من مقطع فيديو نشر في الحادي والعشرين من
هذا الشهر يوم الاثنين الماضي لا يمكن
الجزم بالمكان الذي ظهر فيه اخر مره ولكن
التقرير الاعلاميه تفيد بانه كان في احدى
الدول الافريقيه حيث نشر هذا مقطع الفيديو
هذا الذي شاهدناه قبل قليل والتقطت منه
هذه الصوره قبل ان يغادر بريكوجين الدوله
الافريقيه غير المعلومه باتجاه روسيا
المعلومات تشير الى ان بريكوجين كان
موجودا في مدينه في دوله مالي هذه اكثر
الترجيحات وفق التقارير الاعلاميه حتى هذه
اللحظه ولكن كما اشرنا هذا الامر غير مؤكد
انتقل بريكوجين بطائرته من مالي في
افريقيا الى موسكو على بعد حوالي سته الاف
كيلو متر
انتقل بريكوجين يوم الحادي والعشرين من
هذا الشهر اي يوم الاثنين ومن هناك كان من
المتوقع ان تتحرك طائره الخاصه التي
شاهدناها تتحرك من موسكو الى سان بطرسبيرج
ولكنها سقطت في منتصف الطريق بين المكانين
بين موسكو اذا نحن نتحدث عن هذه المنطقه
الغربيه
من الكرملين مقر الرئاسه الروسيه في
العاصمه اذا من هذه النقطه انطلقت طائره
بريكوجين من مطار تشيرمينتيفو وكانت
متوجهه الى
ولكنها سقطت في على المنطقه الشماليه
الغربيه من ولايه فيرت على الحدود بين
نوفوغراد سقطت الطائره بعد 26 دقيقه من
اقلاعها من المطار
وانقطعت الاتصالات بها عند الساعه السادسه
و 11 دقيقه من مساء يوم امس انقطعت
الاتصالات وانقطعت وصول او قطعه صوره هذه
الطائره على الرادارات حتى هذه اللحظه لا
يمكن الجزم بالطريقه التي سقطت فيها هذه
الطائره ولكن هذه الطائره سقطت هنا هناك
تقارير اعلاميه تقول بان الطائره اسقطت
بمضادات ارضيه وهناك تقارير تقول بان
قبطان الطائره فقد السيطره على الطائره
وبالتالي اسقطت ولكن السلطات الروسيه حتى
الان بالاعلان الرسمي تقول انها فتحت
تحقيقا جنائيا في سبب سقوط
طائره
ولكن حتى الان لا يمكن تاكيد او نفي مقتل
زعيم شركه فاجن